Spunem că suntem liberi atunci când facem ce vrem. Dar de unde vin lucrurile pe care le vrem?
Obiceiul, frica și privirea celorlalți ne influențează alegerile. Uneori, firele se văd abia după ce ne-am mișcat.
Libertatea ar putea începe nu prin negarea acestor influențe, ci prin capacitatea de a le observa.
Poți avea două opțiuni și totuși să nu înțelegi de ce una te atrage. Numărul ușilor nu spune întreaga poveste.
O preferință poate fi repetată din obișnuință. O alta poate fi examinată, discutată și schimbată.
Diferența propusă aici este între a urma o dorință și a putea întreba dacă acea dorință merită urmată.
Nu trebuie să ieșim din lume pentru a reflecta. Uneori, schimbarea începe printr-o pauză înaintea unui gest obișnuit.
De ce vreau asta? Ce teamă încerc să evit? Ce s-ar schimba dacă aș privi situația din alt loc?
Reflecția nu șterge dorințele. Le face vizibile și lasă loc pentru o relație diferită cu ele.
O dorință poate părea urgentă și totuși să contrazică ceva mai important pentru noi.
În această perspectivă, a fi liber înseamnă și a putea pune în balanță consecințele, valorile și relațiile.
Nu există o formulă care decide întotdeauna corect. Există însă un exercițiu de judecată pe care îl putem învăța.
Luciditatea nu este doar o problemă personală. Educația, instituțiile și tehnologia pot ajuta reflecția sau o pot împiedica.
Un mediu bun oferă timp, explicații și posibilitatea de a spune nu. Nu doar mai multe butoane de apăsat.
Putem judeca un sistem și prin întrebarea: îi ajută pe oameni să înțeleagă și să-și revizuiască propriile alegeri?
Libertatea nu este prezentată aici ca absență totală a influențelor. Este o capacitate de a lucra conștient cu ele.
Învățăm să observăm, să întrebăm și uneori să ne schimbăm direcția. Această practică rămâne imperfectă și deschisă.
Cât din ceea ce numim alegere este repetiție? Și unde am putea crea un mic spațiu pentru o decizie cu adevărat a noastră?